Watch ital.
Well, hello, fans of brilliant television and welcome to watch ital.
I'm your host.
Danny Blanco television shows like cars have engines that determine
how they can move a healthy engine is critical.
If you don't want your storyline to spot a are out two or three seasons in you
really need dynamic infrastructure that can drive plot points for years,
the office tortured itself through the agonizing simmer of tension between Jim
and Pam.
It's always sunny channeled its power via an endless procession of outrageous
uniquely American ignorance, breaking bad juxtaposed,
a domestic sludge do veggie bacon with a McBeth and tragedy,
thus completely changing the television paradigm back at the start of the 2010s.
And in 2019,
the cutting edge state of the art craft work and TV engineering is done on
Adam McKay and Jesse Armstrong's succession. Only two seasons in,
and this story has evidently shown the potential to join the Pantheon of
masterpieces in storytelling.
Successions engine operates through a heart hitting stomach churning,
psychodrama of, humiliation, and submission. I wanna see you little piggy.
Eat, fight for your sausages. Piggy. I, I, no, no half hearted. I, I won put,
I, I, I, I.
It's also a Coke. Add adult arrested development type of dark comedy. The issue.
Here, sir, is that everyone hates you.
And when it comes to certain characters like Tom and Greg,
the narrative morphs into a claustrophobic spectacle that CAS its poor
participants into an absurdist play. They make.
A Cajun chicken link. We need just how I like it,
but that's not how you're supposed.
To like it.
So first and foremost is this juxtaposition of different styles.
Sometimes it's house of cards or game of Thrones and at others,
it's the office playing.
Like a pro see L to the OG.
They call it SCR what the electric city script, what the.
Electric city watch,
these cuts and the way the camera hangs on the actor's faces. They.
You up. Your mom and dad. They do not mean to, but they do.
They fill you up with faults.
They had and add some extra just for you.
Stylistically.
The show is obsessed with setting a parallel between the serious necessary
discussion and an absolute irony that makes it impossible to make any meaningful
progress. I guess.
What I want is for you to tell us how you were feeling, how.
I'm feeling. Mm-hmm <affirmative>. I feel
I need to check my emails. It's not a.
Feeling bad. Maybe don't deny dad's feeling.
Shift.
It frustrates its own possibility of resolution by really strengthening the
prerogative of each character to be fully themselves. Honesty.
You see everybody, do you see.
Honesty?
A few moments later.
You are spared. If you tell the truth and I just told you the truth, oh,
there are.
Rules, right? Did you know something, Greg?
There are no rules.
Over there. Secondly,
all of the characters act within an ethos of distrust and cynicism.
There are very few principles. The character is a spouse. In fact,
values of any sort are Bandi about as UN essential epiphenomenon that make no
material difference in the world.
Kind of against my principles, your principles crack don't be an.
You don't have principles. Dude. ATN is a very toxic element in the culture.
Seriously. Okay. The name me one, a principle that you have, I don't know,
like I'm against racism. I'm against racism. True. He's gone.
I mean Nazis. Terrible, right? Nazis. Yeah. Yeah,
yeah. They're they're the worst. Yeah, sure. We all hate Nazis.
Only one belief, reigns Supreme winning. Ah, I.
Will.
Win. If you let anything other than the best strategy cloud,
your judgment like love politics or truth,
then you will be tossed to the wolfs. Succession is thus at heart.
A show about how unadulterated American competitiveness has rotted the core of
the American family and effectively turned the Roy family into this heartless
genetic carnival, baby.
Kenny family.
Logan, as a character views, any sense of emotion as a source of weakness.
You have to be a killer.
You must a killer to win and you must be willing to kill your own kin.
In this regard, succession shares more with the classic Greek tragedies,
like the Oria poli and TNY Madea. And of course,
Oedipus Rex and all orders of other fiction that are obsessed with PIDE and
other taboos. This is what its dramatic angle authenticity.
Despite the constant slew of comedy, I'm worried slash.
Excited in case he actually kills Kendall. I mean, he might kill him,
could go for him. He could kill him, man. It'd be so weird. If he killed him.
The show's engine also features an injunction against any psychologist.
The therapist is really the first person.
We see speak any truth to Logan's power and act for which he ultimately pays by
losing all his teeth in a moment of cosmic retribution.
When we say the show really has the imperative against psychology, we mean it,
this clearly stems from a deep, deep source of trauma,
but that trauma by the logic of the show can never be revealed.
The truth about one's past or their emotion composition is an event horizon.
That's impossible to look into the whole mystery with Roman and the dog cage is
again reflective of that.
And so is all the joking about the brothers molesting one another.
You'll notice a lot of shows set up these types of secrets and it'll be
important to look at how they're dealt with. For example,
BoJack horseman waited years to get into exactly why it's ti anti-hero is so
messed up and that mystery continues to drive interest in season six.
There's also a reflective jealousy that Logan has of his own kids because
they've gotten to live a life without any financial worries whatsoever.
You're so jealous of what you've given your own kids.
You can't handle it. You can't, you, you.
You can't work it out.
So the show's pistons feature a simultaneity here of envy and pity.
In fact, we, as the viewer are constantly conditioned to both envy and pity.
The characters of you might be slightly jealous of their status and riches,
but ultimately the inhumanity of such high stakes makes it impossible for anyone
to have any sort of normal relationship with their sibling.
When I talk to each other.
Norman, talk about.
The, their parent, their colleague, or their significant other.
The competition has seeped in and poisoned every aspect of each character's
life. And that begins first and foremost with the family patriarch.
This really emerges in the finales for both season one and two
In season one.
When Ken approaches Logan with the letter and the declaration of war against
him, the family patriarch answers the door by calling him son on through son
and is shaving in the bathroom in his underwear. He's naked.
This type of staging is pretty stereotypical, but it sets up the ensuing drama.
Well, because before the final scene,
we're get given a new reference of vulnerability as this scene develops.
It's apparent just how hard Kendall is trying. And you really have to ask,
does Logan buy this mask? Ken is wearing Ken's face here, reflects seething,
anger, frustration, and embarrassment. He's showing weakness. He,
his justification of doing the right thing. He's immediately dismissed.
The show, spends the whole of season one building up to this moment.
But the father figure remains ominously powerful.
That which gives Kendall his power is that which makes him immobile.
It's an impossible Gordian knot for him to untie. So it's surprising, shocking.
Even when at the episodes end,
Logan does not act bench fully after Kendall's crash.
Even though he won as indeed betrayed by his son just a day earlier,
Logan is swing into the position of power and he's doing it gracefully.
Not by rubbing Ken's face in it, but by being kind.
Now this has a dual effect. The direct meaning is that Logan is human,
and this is a bit of a tender moment.
He forgives his son for what the world wouldn't on the other.
There's something even more sinister going on because this is a whole new level
of psychological Forry for Ken it's off the charts,
how much this is going to mess him up.
And his father must be acting in that knowledge. Of course,
that's something unsaid. And the scene itself is kind of heartwarming.
So it's really difficult for any viewer to assess this strain between text and
subtext is what makes it really good TV and the capacity for the show writers to
repeatedly generate attention between surface knowledge and unconscious
assumptions is a sure sign of health in its engine. As you're watching,
you're also tense because you realize Logan could snap any second.
The show's emotional register works constantly through these types of bursts and
undeveloped epiphanies lifting toward the kind of virtuosic vulnerability and
self exposure associated with say jab,
that improvisational capacity for emotion is everywhere,
but this ability is not something that is ever going to function as the object
of the scene. Um, to put it another way, the show is about emotions,
but it never discusses emotions.
I, I really can't but uh,
okay. Thank you.
All of this context is crucial to fully understand what exactly happens at the
end of season two to love,
to truly love is to give someone the opportunity to kill you.
What could you possibly kill that you love so much?
It would make the sunrise.
Again. It's the sacrificial lamb dynamic. Okay. We do what we must to win.
So when Logan acts somewhat receptive to the idea of him taking the ax for the
cruises scandal or when the character's so blindly discussed,
who should be tossed to the wolves in the yacht scenes at the end of season two,
that's what allows for that laid back Monch Shant,
but simultaneously terrified attitude.
All the characters comport themselves with and Logan,
at least on some implicit level must know that it has to be him.
That is sacrificed. We've been discussing text and subtext.
And we've stated that this shows core principle is the text of competition.
That is what drives its logic. But as we see in this scene,
there's also the value of family of something that really does exist.
Tough. Okay? We stick together.
Most things don't exist.
The Ford motor company highly exists as just a time saving expression
for a collection of financial interests. But
this exists because family it's a family.
We are a family.
It's exactly in this type of a situation wherein what you say matters.
It also doesn't.
I don't know. I don't know. I'm just, I'm not saying you I'm.
Just saying after all,
everyone is going to defend themselves and point the finger somewhere else.
So whoever manages to completely transcend that dynamic of blame and
narcissistic self-preservation will win. And that man is indeed Kendall.
It can only be Kendall Logan at the beginning of this talk here points attention
to the fact that it should be himself to take the blame,
but that no one in the inner circle will accept his sacrifice.
Someone else must come in and carry out the will of God.
Hence the kiss of Judas here that Ken, once again gives his father.
The dialogue makes you think on the surface that Logan is justifying the
sacrifice of Kendall, but the subtext here,
he emerges as dominant because it's really a justification of why Ken should
instead kill Logan.
It is this reverse engineering that makes the show so brilliant this time
though, unlike in season one,
Ken is there to calmly accept the necessary he makes no fuss, no drama.
He is calm and collected. Logan gives him the prerogative of murder.
Very easily could have prevented the situation, but he improvises on the fly.
Obviously Logan's willing to go through with Ken taking the blame,
but that's only because no one has proven themselves strong enough to rest the
throne from him. Truth revelation.
A genuine moment of change requires some performance, some true remarkability.
And so Logan's stranglehold on power can only be broken this way because it's
such a crucial central tenant of the show's engine.
You can't change something like that without also having some modification and
another major structure in the show.
And that comes through this act of cleansing, that Kendall forces on the family.
Now an engine is not some monolithic beast that pre determines a show's success.
It is a fictitious entity that we just talk about when we want to contextualize
how exactly a show is built up and what can make it successful.
Show writing requires constant tinkering, polishing,
fine tuning to maintain a healthy engine.
And there's no way of knowing if a new car part will break down the whole system
by say, introducing a new character,
or if sticking to the same materials for a decade will turn your car into a heap
of useless metal. As was the case with how I met your mother and Dexter.
Some problems are just too vast to actually solve without a stroke of genius.
So it's difficult to say exactly where six session might go past season two.
No one can predict that there's a reason. We watched the episodes,
given what we said about competition and Logan,
we really have no idea how the patriarch is going to react to Kendall's kiss of
death. This is the story of success and the impossibility of maintaining it.
How can you,
when there are billions of dollars in play with all eyes on you from the time
you are in a crib with your siblings, it's a succession story.
As old as storytelling itself, it's Lee, it's the godfather,
it's the murder of collect Nera and the ores.
Another parental murder that is ultimately used as the foundation of a whole new
form of justice.
Breaking power is an act that can only be done through bloodshed.
And that's a lesson that succession understands most critically.
These really serious psychologically dense metaphysical narratives are the
most modern thing. Someone in 2019 could write.
This has been watch it pal. And I'm your host,
Danny Blanco stay tuned for why succession is the best show on television.
Part two by subscribing. Now.